hello my name is dr. Thomas cos Chesky
I'm the director of biology at CM bio
innovations and talk to you today about
their micro physiological systems that
we've been developing and how we use
these tools the human specific drug
discovery and drug development the
reason that we develop these tools is a
variety of reasons but particularly for
those articulated in this slide which
show that actually most of the molecules
that are now developed by pharmaceutical
companies don't make it to become d
medicines I'm sure many people are aware
on 90% on average of all drugs that
going to phase 1 clinical trials don't
become an improvements in and don't make
it through the clinical trial process
and this is mainly due to both reasons
of safety and of efficacy we certainly
strongly believe that this is driven by
a lack of relevant preclinical models
that allow the generation of new
therapeutics to reach clinical trials
and that are human specific and
therefore we're going to treat human
diseases while having limited toxicity
profiles so as a scientist in
preclinical drug development there are a
wide variety of tools available for you
to analyze disease biology and also
therapeutic efficacy in toxicology of
compounds so these range from everything
from in silico modeling through to
in-vitro cell culture and this can take
the form of more basic 2d cell culture
now using 3d and organoid technologies
and and then into micro physiological
systems also known as organs on chips
all the way through to in vivo so all of
these different tools are available to
people and they have all have a variety
of different benefits and pros and cons
and and certainly the the scientist has
a job to do to understand which of these
is most relevant to the questions
they're trying to pass
traditionally in vitro preclinical
biology has been done on 2d plastic for
many years researchers have used
standards cell lines which have grown on
plastic plates these cell lines are
grown for many many years they
continually pass ours and they're and
they're immortalized and don't always
represent the biological features and
functions of the human body that they're
looking to try and represent nonetheless
these cells are easy to handle they
produce wonderful statistically
significant data but when it comes to
translating to the human disease they
struggle to do that so organs on chips
or micro physiological systems which I
refer to SMPS or advanced in-vitro
platforms for culturing and testing
responses related to human physiology
and disease and there are a number of
criteria that we and the community now
define to make up one of these
technologies is so these technologies
often and most commonly used primary
human selves so these should be the most
translatable material to a human being
we look to grow these cells in cell and
tissue like structures with which have
three dimensions with the aim to try and
mimic tissue and organ function in vitro
and these platforms a key feature is
that they utilize fluidic flow to move
media around these platforms to allow
cells than to experience biomechanical
stimuli and shear forces that they would
receive in vivo and also in particular
we think very carefully about how we
control the dosing of compounds and
therapeutics into this platform so that
the dosing can is closely possibly
represent the kind of drug responses
that occur in vivo so mvs platforms are
be utilized across the drug discovery
process
so in early sort of target discovery
target ID we see a place for these
technologies for example using disease
models to allow people to explore the
presence of certain targets and how
these might change as we go through the
discovery process there are particular
applications around dmpk and
safety where these tools can be very
beneficial to predict how the how a
particular compound is going to behave
in a human in a clinical development and
then also then finally there's a place
for these technologies to complement
clinical development thinking about ways
in which clinical trials can be designed
I'm looking at precision medicine and
understanding how different patient
cohorts may behave differently to
particular so @cm bio
we're a uk-based biotech company we've
been building advanced in vitro platform
such as MPs for for nearly ten years we
build single organ and multi organ mps
platforms and we utilize these for both
efficacy and toxicity testing of
different molecules and the key feature
the key thing we try to build into our
technology is that these mps platforms
are straightforward to set up there are
both robust and simple for people to use
so they can be installed at any lab
anywhere in the world the technology
that we've been building over a number
of years is built originally from IP
generated from Professor Linda Griffith
at MIT and most prominently and over the
last couple of years we've been
collaborating with the FDA and
particularly the group within cedar to
understand how these tools can now be
used for regulatory science and be
incorporated into R&D submissions and
become a real workhorse of the
pharmaceutical industry to answer a
range of different questions that people
have
around the development of new menses so
the basis of sandbars MPs platform which
is known in physio MINIX is the use of
different consumable plates so a key
feature and a differentiator of our
technology is that our plates are open
well they have the same footprint and
standard multi-well cell culture plates
but they are entirely bespoken generated
for our platform so each of the plates
has has different designs different
wells shapes and structures to culture
different organ and tissue mimics so we
can pick and choose these for different
assays and applications so for example
we have a liver model and an Associated
liver plate and this is a 12 well plate
so it contains 12 individual liver
cultures we can then break more advanced
multi organ platforms where there is
different chambers I'm connected
together which contain different organ
structures and fluidic lelee all of
these interface with our our common
hardware system that you see in the
right hand corner of this slide and this
is very simple to install it sits on the
bench top and Innis any standard
incubator and allowing people to simply
kind of set this up they can then pick
and choose the consumable plate that
they're interested in with The
Associated application and then can
start work so to show you a little bit
more about the plates and and how they
work and how we utilize them and here
I'll show you a couple of examples of
how the fluidics work within these
plates so within all of the consumable
plates we have inbuilt micro fluidics
micro fluidics perfuses the media either
around an individual tissue structure or
between those different cellular tissue
models and i mentioned i'm allowing them
to english to connect so on the
left-hand side here you see a diagram of
there are an individual well on our
liver platform and the media interviews
is around each of these individual wells
there's there's
three dimensional scaffold held within
this well I'm sure I'm going to show you
some more details off shortly the media
/ fuses directly through this scaffold
recirculates around again and it comes
back to the scaffold so the cells held
within plating and weather particularly
within the scaphoid are continually
exposed to media flow and the mind
biomechanical stimulator this print so
we can use those same plant features to
then as I say connect different wilds
chambers together so in the multi organ
scenario and is a aquatic complex
example shown here where we have seven
individual chambers connected together
we have individual microbe plants
connecting each one of these chambers
allowing us to flow media around the
platform in a similar way to cardiac
output in your in the human body and
there are we have exquisite control
around how media flows around its body
so we can control the flow between two
organs or three and beyond and this
allows us to control both stimuli that
each individual organ receives and very
closely but then also how media flows
around the whole platform allowing us to
control for example on platform
pharmacokinetic profiles so that and
bioavailability so cells and tissues on
the platform and exposed to a human
relevant concentrations at home so to
set up an experiment and we have a broad
range of ways of doing this we we don't
define explicitly what cell types or
cell sources individual people should
use so we have what we generally
encourage people to use primary human
cells and these platforms that's what
they're designed for we feel these are
the most translationally relevant
material to use in building these models
but equally stem cell derived cell
sources can be used we have some
individuals who used tissue slices on
our platforms as well as other sort of
commercially available cell lines and
then these cultures are induced and we
generally keep them alive for
significant periods of time so key
feature of NPs platforms is real
longevity of culture so most experiments
that we run with these platforms last on
a number of weeks rather than just a
number of days only then we think very
hard as already mentioned how we then
introduce therapeutics and drugs onto
these platforms and when we dose
compounds onto the platforms in a way
that is physiologically and
translationally relevant there at the
end of any experiment or during the
experiment samples can be taken of both
the media and the cells to do a really
wide range of different endpoint
analysis to understand cell health and
cell function in attire so we can do
full mix analysis of them on each
individual micro tissue to understand
its transcriptomic or proteomic profile
we can do a lot wide range of different
microscopy techniques to look at cell
morphology or we can look at
translationally relevant by market so
using this MPs platform we can really
look to answer a whole range of
different questions and using a range of
different tissue structures looking at
both sort of add me and tox type
questions but also there looking at
disease modeling and looking also at new
modalities we use large molecules gene
editing tools in this platform and they
work very successfully at one particular
area where we think this technology we
utilized more in the future is in the
precision medicine space this is not
something that's been done a lot of just
yet um it's one area that we're marching
towards quite fast so next I'm going to
show you a little bit of information
about our NPS liver platform and how we
build this and how we can then utilize
in so as I showed you already we have a
12 valve plate if a platform each of
these whales contains a 3d engineered
collagen coated scaffold and this
cathode contains 301 individual channels
and what we do is seed into these
channels Jerry primary human liver cells
so principally primary path sites we use
will also include all range of other non
parenchymal cells and even additional
immune cells if we want to and over the
first couple of days inside the scaffold
cells go in as a single cell suspension
and they slowly form up to form
three-dimensional individual micro
tissues so what we achieve after a
couple of days is it's three-dimensional
micro tissues arrayed across this
scaffold and then what we do is think
about and treat this scaffold I can
biopsy tissue so there is clearly some
variability across the entire whole but
we treat the scaffold as one whole piece
within a which with the array of micro
tissues across it we can remove
individual scaffolds from the plate at
different time points without affecting
the other Wells on the platform so we
can do very straightforwardly to very
elegant time force analyses and we can
obviously sample very easily the media
from the platform so we can then look at
a range of different biomarkers so some
are shown here and here we do a simple
comparison just showing how standard
liver biomarkers and things like albumin
sip activities transporters all of these
are both promoted in the presence of
this 3d perfuse platform and actually
the other thing we know very well is the
platform provides longevity to these or
patek functions allowing a very large
window to do develop so as an example of
the kind of athletes that we can build
on this liver platform going to show you
how we build on one of the fatty liver
disease also known also known as NAT
fold and it's more aggressive for mash
so for those who are not aware now she's
a metabolic liver disease which now
affects with pretty large proportion of
people in the Western world and it's
directly linked to the obesity epidemic
it's really one diabetes and and now
she's defined by a couple of key
features so principally is defined by
liver
sorry fat in the liver in the absence of
excessive alcohol consumption and this
leads to a number of key things first of
all it leads to excessive liver
inflammation and then it leads to liver
fibrosis this liver fibrosis ultimately
leads to scarring and damage of the
liver which eventually will become
cirrhotic and therefore irreversible as
we currently stand today there are no
currently approved drugs
for the treatment of match and so as a
result there's a there's a large desire
to design these therapeutics to treat
this disease for all the people that now
have it so we took our MPs liver model
and asked how we can build a model of
human match or fatty liver disease and
the way that we do that is described in
this schematic so we take primary human
poop for self priming even parasites I
mean human I take stellate cells and
then a cocktail fats sugars insulin etc
we bring all these together onto our NPS
platform and and then we can
recapitulate the human disease we can
then introduce the therapeutics of
interest to test how they were pensee
reverse this phenotype a disease
phenotype that we see they're just using
so some simple mean of fresh and
staining we can see the presence of good
for sales and stellate cells so these
integrate within the three-dimensional
liver tissues that are that I've already
shown you and we incorporate
physiologically relevant ratios of
stomach cells um and we can do so
actually but also in a variable manner
so if we want to look at mechanistic
studies we can run the model for example
without without stellate cells we can
increase the number of stellate cells we
can find different donors with different
genetic backgrounds so we can explore a
really wide range of different
magnifications of this model to explore
how a particular pathway is develop or
how particular targets will change
different patient populations and when
we take this model and explore is
transcriptomic profile we see a couple
of very clear things
so the overall transcriptional profile
it's modeled very clearly Maps the
primary human - and we do that by
exploring online databases asking the
database in an unbiased fashion what a
disease State does it observe and it
very clearly identifies two states on
the left hand side identifies the
transcriptional profile of our model to
be human - then we go one level further
we can look at the key genes associated
with nash and there are some very
publications now showing key gene sets
of of 200-300 genes that are known to be
up and down regulated in its disease
state and when we look at all of those
very specific genes associated with this
disease and see if those are changing in
the right way in our model and we see
very good associations with with with
our model nearly the vast majority of
these genes are changing and that's in
real contrast to some of the classical
mirror models of Nash that have been
used over many years and these simply
don't recapitulate they're a
transcriptional profile of human nature
so our MDS model recapitulates the
really key features that are mentioned
about this disease so for example we see
significant influence in liver
inflammation occurring in the model we
can track that using multiplex so it's
kind analysis and we see is the model
progress is a range of Honshu markers
being promoted and we've developed a
confocal microscopy approach to look at
the presence of ECM proteins are being
laid down in the 3d tissue structures
within the scaffold and we see these
only in the presence of the national of
the national or if we make it more
basics Thea ptosis just liver loading
model we don't see this we don't see
this fibrosis and then finally obviously
we can also measure fat loading as the
core basis for this disease stain and we
see the cells become fatty and we we
have methodologies to quantify this
using alright
and so to demonstrate the utility of
this um we've done work look at how we
can put compounds into this model to
reduce and a knockdown the disease
phenotype so I'm just going to just
showing you here data looking at at that
fibrosis imaging endpoint that we can
look at the presence of extracellular
collagen one and smooth muscle actin
when we dose two compounds there in late
stage of clinical development these are
obese colic acid labeled here is OCA and
elephant all labeled here is e.l.f so
both of these molecules are in phase 3
clinical trial known to be fairly
effective against nash
in another preclinical and clinical
studies we put these molecules into our
system and physiologically relevant
concentrations we get very clear
dose-dependent
knockdown of both SMA as shown by the
graph on on the top right and a collagen
type one on the bottom right so this is
a this is a very powerful output
it's very reproducible and really
validates the use of this model for for
doing drug development and drug
discovery for furniture so I don't want
to move away from from the last model
and show you a little bit about how we
use our MDS platform for drug absorption
metabolism type approaches so we can do
this first of all using our our liver
model that we've already been talking
about so we published this paper a
couple of years ago showing how our
liver model in its healthy state can be
used to predict a human drug clearance
what we did was to take six different
probe fairly standard molecules we put
them in the system and we do this with a
whole range of different donor materials
we see where these drugs be metabolized
away we can see the presence of human
specific phase 1 phase 2 metabolites
what we can then do is take this data
and extrapolate it forward and predict
the clearance of these compounds in
humans so what you see here on the right
hand side is a comparison between data
from the NPS platform and clinical data
so in the grey dots and the graph on the
right hand side you see clearance data
for the clearance of lidocaine and then
the red line with the kind of shady bar
around it you see the clearance of
lidocaine in our model and how it
overlays really really nicely with with
the clinical appearance data so we can
get genuine translation from the in
vitro through to the in vivo drug
clearance so to extend our models of for
dmpk we don't just need liver there are
obviously other organs involved so we've
also developed models of the human gut
I'm so to do this we we use a trans well
based approach where we have a co
culture I've got epithelial cells
uncultured on a diffused trans all set
up
so here we have a different well
structure as you see in the schematic on
the left hand side and what we get in
this scenario with this perfuse
co-culture first of all is an intestinal
epithelial barrier that produces mucus
and we compare this to stand in static
keiko to type approaches and as well as
producing mucus what we see is a clear
change in morphology and a
three-dimensional nature to this tissue
so when we look at IFC staining as you
see here on the left hand side the
morphology of the tissue is complex its
deep and fitting nicely closely
represents the morphology of the human
gut and we compare that as a standard
Keiko to cultures which are a monolayer
of single cells and when we start to
look at other functional responses and
outputs from this model and one thing we
see very clearly is that thicker to
standard Keiko two models are known to
be very very tight so when we look at
tear tissue integrity assessments of
these these Keiko two models on the
right hand side you see very high values
for the k-cup only models and when we
have this perfused co-culture system you
have much reduced here so the tissue
integrity is is much closely represents
the human gut and then we can then start
to measure that by looking at drug
permeability and so for example we see
the system to be much more permeable and
we see that through for example depth
and permeability shown on the bottom
right but we can combine some of these
cultures together to look at multi organ
interaction studies to actually
replicate absorption and metabolism in
the same setup using a gut liver and yes
so on the right hand side here you see
how these two organ systems can be set
up actually in the same well in a
relatively simple manner so you have the
gut trans wall at the top and then we
can have a empathic issue structure at
the bottom and here what we can do is
put compounds into the system we can
dose them into the able side of the
trans well we can wash them be absorbed
through the gas and then be metabolized
away by the liver so what we see for
example with that - and I'm going to be
relatively fastly absorbed by the gas um
and metabolize the wave on the live of
i69 that's exactly what we see in our
model also we see a relatively fast
absorption and then in the Tabitha's
away for example when we compare that to
a different type of drug like atenolol
this is a very slowly absorbed drug and
it's a really clear compound so in our
model we see this very slow absorption
I'm in the presence of the gut model and
then it simply accumulates in the system
because there is no kidney model it with
our collaborators at MIT and we've also
done more advanced got liver interaction
studies with where here the gut on
deliver our own separate chambers and
again we can we can do studies with back
low for now and what we do here is again
close lackeys toast in the apical side
of the gut NPS it goes through the gut
we can detect it and we can measure it
coming through the gap I'm going through
that round into the mixing chamber going
to the liver and then over the course of
48 hours being and 72 hours being
metabolized away being disappearing from
the system so one final example I want
to give you is it is on how we use our
system to culture lung cells and then
how we point this in a toxicology type
space so we can culture along cells
again using a trans or based approach
here we have an air liquid interface so
we have an air side of the lung
epithelium and a blood side or a media
side and this is again where the fluid
flow is and in this scenario we are me
human liver cell sorry from a human lung
cells and these create a number of the
key physiological features of the
product of lung and here we're looking
at bronchial epithelium so these
bronchial philia have a thickness to
their structure as we see so this is not
again not a single layer of cells they
produce micro villi so these can be seen
both on the ist staining but also by
using alpha tubulin staining in the in
the iaf image here we get no very nice
Junction formation and this then I'll
annals again we can measure this
integrity
using tear and this long system just
like the girl system will also produce
mucus so this is top down a phase
contrast image looking at the production
of mucus after just a few days in
culture we can quantify this
and again these cultures can be can be
cultured for extended periods of time so
the a lot of the data I've shown you
here will shows goes out to 28 days we
have a really extended culture period
for these lung epithelial cells allowing
you to have a real wide window as a
window to juice balance we can then link
and these liver cultures so in these
lung cultures to liver cultures to
potentially again make multi organ
setups to look at how aerosol lines and
agents potentially have acute but also
effects in secondary organs what we did
in this study was to create a long liver
Co culture and first of all we
demonstrated that the two organs could
be cultured together for an extended
period of time so we looked at standard
metrics of liver function I'm here
showing you albumin and a lung function
so we have the tier measurements over 12
days and these are very stable using a
single media that's connecting these two
together and when we took this set up we
can introduce an insult to the system
and and we see that the lung culture um
established by its insole and is dosing
in this insole and in the presence of
the liver the liver provides a
protective effect including metabolizes
away somehow the the insole allowing the
lung to survive for much longer
following this chronic in so we can use
so that's measured here by you looking
at tear but we can also see this through
imaging and so we can see this genuine
crosstalk between these two organs so
it's very hopefully what I've shown you
is that mps platforms are our
preclinical tools that are really
available now and these available for
use for both safety net kisi testing of
new therapeutics new compounds but also
can be used for chemical when
and consumer products testing
particularly in the ecology space and we
now see that that these platforms are
being really taken up and evaluated
fully by the pharmaceutical industry and
being adopted to start making project
specific and compound specific decisions
let's see them bio a really key thing is
is that we're building these platforms
to make them reliable robust usable for
people I'm easy to set up and flexible
so that people can move and easily
switch between for example liver models
and models or analytical models together
so we have these single and multi organ
NPS models I'm now available with The
Associated biological assays so I thank
you very much for listening I hope you
enjoyed the presentation if you have
more questions and please reach out to
us there's a lot more information about
our models we have a whole back catalog
of peer-reviewed publications about the
models that we've built over a number of
years both for ourselves and with our
collaborators in academia and in
industry so I'd encourage you to go to
our website at CNM - bio.com to find out
more information and and thank you